I can tell you conservative something
you will never get young people to want
to conserve a society and an economy
that is not working for them we will not
overcome woke nihilism as long as young
people are locked out of the housing
market Unable to pair up unable to have
kids unable to plan for the future I
know it's difficult and I know that
whoever solves the housing crisis May
well pay the price at The Ballot Box
this is true of many pressing issues too
or at least you think it is but you did
not get into politics to get reelected
you got into politics to make a
difference we are in the fight of our
lives and if courage means anything it
means doing the right thing and being
willing to take the punishment if you
have to let me say it again all Death is
certain we do not get to choose whether
we live or die we only get to choose
whether we live before we die